In this section, we're gonna talk about
some of the settings in Lumen and how to adjust them
to get the best possible quality for your scene.
So let's get started.
You'll see here on this slide,
we have an image of our post process volume,
and we're looking at the initial
global illumination settings.
We're gonna talk a bit about these in just a bit
and go back between the slides and Unreal
to get a better sense of how things work
and the control that you have.
But we for sure will be breaking down these values
so you understand exactly the power at your fingertips.
Let's go ahead and go to Unreal and get things started
by pulling in a post process volume.
So one of the first things we're gonna need
for quality control when it comes to Lumen
is a post process volume.
Overall, when it comes to baking also,
this can help with visuals,
but we're gonna be using a more directional,
or I should say a movable light scenario,
where our GI is going to update on the fly.
And we're gonna talk about how to actually edit
some of those settings.
So let's go ahead and pull up the post process volume.
Now I can use it using the place actor tab
if I wanted to,
and I can go in here and choose volumes if I wanted,
or I can even do a simple search.
But a quick way to get there is simply clicking
on the quickly add to project button here,
the box with the green plus,
and I can go down to volumes, look for it,
or simply click once into get content
and type in post process volume.
We have a post process volume in our scene.
And typically you wouldn't use two
unless you're going from particular look
or several different shots.
But in this particular case, I've activated one here,
so you just kind of get an idea of what I'm doing.
One of the first things you want to do is make sure
that we are set to infinite extend unbound.
Lumen is okay with this.
In cases with ray tracing,
you wanna limit your post process volume size
to the area that you wanna calculate
because ray tracing is kind of expensive.
But Lumen uses some of that ray tracing technology.
It's a bit of a hybrid and it uses it to its advantage.
So if we do turn this on, we should be fine.
And it works just great.
If we go back up to our initial settings,
you'll see that our global elimination setting method,
we wanna make sure that it's set to Lumen.
Now, anytime you can override what you may have already
in your project settings,
and you have that option with the post process volume,
we can also go in here and go
to Lumen Scene Lighting Quality.
So this will give us a little bit better visuals overall
in our reflections, as well as just our scene in general.
We also have Lumen Scene Detail.
This is gonna be very helpful too.
This will help us represent our smaller objects better.
And Lumen Scene View Distance.
This is going to help us for larger scenes
and looking at our range of sky shadowing.
Remember, the higher numbers that you punch into here
could be higher, could be at a higher
or will be a higher cost for your GPU.
So just make sure you keep in mind
what graphics card you're using
and overall what you have set up.
We also have Final Gather.
This can help reduce noise.
Or remember, you wanna start low and then go high.
We have Max Trace Distance here also
that we can calculate.
And this can help for larger scenes for, you know,
looking at, you'll see here it says values are too small,
will cause a light leaking into large caves
while values that are large will increase GPU cost.
So you really just need to weigh it.
So start with the defaults
and then work your way from there.
And then we have Scene Capture Catch Resolution.
And this is a scale factor
for Lumen Surface Catch Resolution.
For the Scene Capture,
smaller values save GPU memory at a cost and quality.
So again, weigh things with a grain of salt.
And I shouldn't say that, I should,
everything you do, you should also
just look at the big picture.
It's probably a better way to put that.
I mean like, whatever I say take with a grain of salt.
No, you'll see Unreal's really nice as you float over
and it'll tell you what it does.
This is super, super great to have these hot tips in here
as little reminders.
Because as you shuffle through all these different settings
and all these different things such as materials, lighting,
animation, you can get a little preview
to remind you of how things work.
Let's go to the slides for a minute
and we're gonna talk about these
in a little bit more detail.
Then we're gonna take a look at the advanced settings
and what we can do to edit those.
So we see here again,
we look at Lumen Scene Lighting Quality.
It scales Lumen Scene Quality.
Large scales cause a Lumen Scene to be calculated
with a higher fidelity.
Can be visible in reflections
but larger values are GPU expensive.
So remember, always consider your GPU.
And the items that you have on scene.
One of the things I can tell you
which is super important,
you know, hear me repeat it several times,
is Lumen Virtual Shadow Maps and Nanite all work together
and they give you the highest visual fidelity
you can possibly get.
You just have to manage your settings
and your environment as much as possible.
So we have Lumen Scene Detail,
controls the size of the instances
that can be calculated in a scene.
Large settings help smaller objects
but again, it is GPU expensive.
As you get higher, I should say.
Lumen Scene View Distance,
set maximum view distance of the scene
that Lumen maintains by ray tracing against.
Larger values help sky shadowing and GI
and larger values again, can be expensive.
And again, we have Lumen Final Gather,
kind of what we talked about before,
gives you better quality overall
and it can reduce noise but again, can be expensive.
So start low and then go high.
And then we also have Max Trace Distance,
controls the maximum distance that Lumen should trace
while solving lighting, the values.
Now it says values too small will cause light leaking.
So be careful with those numbers.
And then we also have Scene Capture,
Catch Resolution Scale.
Scene Factor for Lumen surface,
catch smaller values, save GPU memory
but in a quality cost.
So the advanced settings that you see in there
are right below where we were before.
So you'll see there's a Lumen quality speed update.
This will make it so that when you change your settings,
they update accordingly.
We also have Final Gather lighting update speed.
This will also help so that things update accordingly.
Now, as you increase those, they are GPU expensive.
So keep in mind the graphics card
that you have under the hood.
There is like a poor man's type of,
I guess you could say exposure.
It's not quite, but basically it is a diffuse boost.
Again, allows brightening by indirect lighting
by calculating material diffuse color.
So it gives you like a little bit of a brightness to it.
And then we also have a light, a skylight leaking,
controls what fraction of the skylight
intensely should be allowed to leak
and can be used for our direction
to keep indoors from being too dark.
And finally, we have full skylight leaking a distance.
So let's talk about these two last one here,
because these two last ones here are very important
to understand that they're the new kids on the block.
They help with accuracy.
Now in previous versions of Unreal with ray tracing,
you needed to use a CVAR to be able to calculate
your skylight in your interior environment.
You'll see that the full skylight leaking distance
controls the distance from receiving surface
where skylight leaking it's full intensity,
large values, AO effect, smaller,
makes skylight leaking flatter.
So you're basically controlling those interiors.
And also on the first one here with skylight leaking,
you're making sure that things don't get too dark
for interiors.
So what I mean by that,
if we go to Unreal in older versions,
or I should say if you're using ray tracing
before Lumen came around,
you would have to type in like skylight,
and you'll see that there is a global illumination
evaluate skylight and global nation
ray tracing skylight contribution.
That's kind of what these two new advanced settings do.
So as I turn these on,
let's go back into, let me click for a second here
and escape out of my output log.
You thought something broke though, didn't you?
That was just a interface thing.
Turn on diffuse skylight leaking
and full skylight leaking distance.
We can control these interiors.
Now you won't see a whole lot of changes sometimes
when you mess with these, there might be a little bit
and some of it required,
depending on how close you are to a scene,
how dark are you in interior, are you in an exterior?
And those things will be more prominent
in this particular scenarios.
Now, if I bump up my final gather,
now you're like, can I go higher?
Now you can, remember you want to start low.
You just have to be careful with these.
It depends on your GPU
and you can actually slow down your frames
and mine isn't really slowing down too bad,
so too bad.
And I removed some of the noise that was occurring here.
So just keep those things in mind.
So right below that,
you'll see that we have reflection control.
And here we can choose what kind of reflections we want.
You can choose ray tracing if you wanted to
and control the ray tracing reflections accordingly,
or you can use a lumen.
And we talked about using hit lighting for reflections
and gives you higher, better quality.
And you can dumb those down as you need.
And you can do a surface catch if you needed to,
but it's really up to you.
And just remember the higher quality,
it's going to look better
in your reflective materials overall.
You can also turn on high quality
translucency reflections,
activating a high quality mirror reflections
on the front layer of that translucent surface.
When on, remember,
it's going to cost a little bit more with your GPU.
Again, the benefit of using lumen
allows you to get global illumination in your reflections,
which is pretty impressive.
And you didn't get that before with ray tracing.
In the next video,
we're going to take a look at lumen visualizers
and how they work.
And then we're also going to look at some tips and tricks
when using lumen overall.